my name is Mike Skinner Schnee I have
two roles here at Yale on the executive
director of the global health Leadership
Institute I'm also I involved in the
green strategy program as the director
of practice and it's a real pleasure to
be here today I'm also very excited to
introduce the concluding panel which is
titled new horizons on humanitarianism
in action but it's also focused as
Shannon was mentioning on the next
generation of people who are kind of be
addressing these issues so I think it's
really exciting to have our colleagues
here today to finish off today's
conference
so I'll just briefly introduce each of
our colleagues and have them presented
and we'll have some Q&A afterwards but
today we're joined by Christina Jeong
who is a senior in Sabre college
completing her BA in architecture she
has been running research based charity
projects since 2011 and his co-founder
of a program called ideation world which
is I just learned is literally just ten
months old it's a nonprofit that
empowers through innovation
she has been directing humanitarian our
connector projects including a Learning
Center construction project in Kakuma
refugee camp in Kenya with local refugee
leaders so we'll hear from Christina
broadly on ideation world we'll also
hear from her colleague her colleague
leegime
long who is a junior in Davenport
College majoring in economics and
statistics Li Jing's academic interest
is in development economics and he has
actively participated in a variety of
multiple data different projects here
while he's been at Yale he as part of
ideation world he will share his
experience in organizing something
called place and develop in displacement
a multidisciplinary competition which is
still in the process of happening where
received over 300 proposals from 34
different countries so we'll learn more
about that project from lijing and
finally we're joined today by Maria
Melchor who is a junior in Moore's
college so is head Panther Beck very
proud to have one of her students with
us today Maria is a political science
major interested particularly in
domestic immigration politics
she has been interested in these issues
since her since she herself immigrated
from Mexico to the Greater New Haven
area and she has spent the past summers
working with resettled refugees here in
the state of Connecticut and with
detained asylum seekers in Texas she's
been involved with the Yale refugee
project and is now the president of that
organization will present a little bit
on that today as well so I'll turn it
over to Christina so thank you so much
thank you very much I'm Christina I'll
see you in architecture major graduating
in a month so today I want to mainly
talk about the young daring adventures
and accidents that led to some veils so
ten months ago I started looking at the
humanitarian architecture done for the
refugee crisis there are so many
problems I'm sure like all of you have
heard of something about like getting
rid of the tents because of like the
protracted situation but essentially
people are still creating versions and
versions of tents and then like
protecting not helping much with this
current situation um and then there's
one thing I noticed through doing my
research on the current architecture
work on refugee camps the one thing that
bothered me a lot is that I don't see
refugees own voices within this whole
process and their own agency addressed
so that's when I decided to go into her
if you can by myself I applied through
Yale fellowship to go into Kakuma
refugee camp the currently the world's
biggest refugee camp in the world was
190,000 refugees from 8 different
nationalities including south
in Sudan Somalia Uganda and all the
surrounding countries so this is a place
where like people have been there for
like 20 years 10 years or like they're
trying to like actually making making a
life happen there like it's it's a place
people actually dwell in so that's why I
decided to go into this place and in the
beginning I spent two months contacting
around 60 NGOs that has works based in
Kenya and all of them rejected me most
of them didn't reply so I went in as a
of course so I went as an individual
through the contact with a refugee
living inside the camp this refugee took
me in he has an organization called
civic solidarity and advocacy in crisis
he provides education programs
that's not provided by any of the
international organizations including
sex and relatives health education on
the NGOs currently are not providing
that because there's a lot of like
religious conflicts and cultural
conflicts between different communities
and they also provide education for men
only since over 15 years old because the
UNHCR only provides education up to
eighth grade which is like younger than
16 years old and their main purpose is
to set up economic independence for
Refugees and for them to have like their
own power to claim their own future
within the refugee camp in this
protected situation
these are Deborah Mary and Albert one
from South Sudan one from Uganda and one
was from Congo DRC so we worked together
on in the beginning learning about all
the opportunities of for Refugees to
like actually develop and address their
own agency inside the camps
so I met Vasco and musa bell the two
people who started this organization and
the team six years ago they came into
the commercial camp as teenagers when
they were 16 in 22 2010 and so we
thought their own communities though
their own houses and started like
feeling like started making this place
their home and in this process they felt
like they felt the responsibility to
help their community because they were
educated
for they came here they graduated from
high school they spoke English and
French but people around them many
people from other countries have never
got the chance to have any education and
adults like the US here doesn't offer
them anything so that's why they started
all the opportunities for Refugees to
have classes and also for to address
like the needs for children as well
something beyond survival something
about living the camp and developing for
a future so Deborah is in charge of the
English and literacy education
she helps was she came in to earth to
camp when she was four years old she
spent 18 years inside the refugee camp
and now she's 22 years old only one year
older than me and she the community is
really like developing their own culture
throughout the 20 years inside the camp
they paint their of their houses on
Christmas space and they actually live
in this place this is something you
never see like our media or like website
because people are somehow just
uncomfortable with like addressing
refugees own power inside like within
within their lives inside the replicants
they have their own like really just
organizations also they set up like
churches and activities for themselves
collecting the materials little by
little and then creating a structure and
the community from nothing so these are
the things that I cared a lot and I
learned a lot inside the can about
people actually constructing making and
living in this place which is why we
decided to do something else before I
left the camp for the first time in
August
I asked Musa Bell who took me into the
camp if I could do anything to help him
because he helped with my own research
and I learned a lot in the camp he told
me you are an architecture student so
why don't we build a school and we
started fundraising together with these
incredible individuals for the projects
and we got $200,000 within the course of
two months to start the school
construction so right now
the construction is happening where I'm
working together with the civil engineer
also a refugee who used to be a civil
engineer in his home country and then we
designed this plot with 12 classrooms
two computer rooms with internet and all
the infrastructure for refugees to
access information as well as getting
education and there are also special
features promoting gender equality
inside the camp inside the school
including like child care center for
women to learn like free from their
children and also like special private
private rooms for adolescent from
different communities to access sex
education without having to go through
the barriers or pressure from their
community and all the workers as you can
see like female males all refugees paid
according to the maximum wall that can
you allow refugees to get for their
monthly salary or compensation so that's
how everything started I realized that
like you don't have to have any plans
you just you just have to like have the
power and the vision to actually start
something and then in this process of
implementing this school project and
learning about refugees I met a really
awesome team including leashing so we
decided to connect everything to the
world and actually make an impact in a
larger range not just inside the Kakuma
refugee camp working with civic beyond
this we thought that we could achieve
something more so leashing is going to
introduce the other projects we're doing
right now
[Applause]
so thank you Miss Tina for introducing
one of the projects of her experience in
one of the projects by the Asian world
the Kakuma Learning Centre and I'm going
to talk about two other projects and it
will feature our competition which will
conclude next weekend great before
talking into the competition I would
like to also introduce a little bit
about the Kenya informal sector teacher
training program which basically address
the problem that a lot of the teachers
in Kenya they are not trained
professionally and we want to bring in
two more resources to the Kenyan
government and also the skews to allow
the teachers to know more at methods
about how to teach your students more in
a more organized manner and also how to
improve according to the feedback from
the students so we basically we first
started from having a pop up training
program which introduced our training
methods on some new ideas on education
to quite some teachers and then later we
started our pilot testing to really test
our methods on around 30 schools to see
how students and can improve and how
teachers can improve their teaching and
then we have also organized a hackathon
which based education on information and
communication technologies ICT to
experiment with new methods of Education
um and before we move on to the
competition I want to briefly introduce
how this project became part of our
project so when I was in Kenya by myself
was wandering around the street I met
two individuals same age they were also
working with internally displaced
population on education so we just like
find it on the street we had a talk like
on the on the walkway and then we
decided while we're of the same age we
spoke the same language we had the same
vision and we're doing exactly the same
things just in different places so
immediately we decided to come together
and start this team so this team is
basically about like all the
coincidences that happened without plan
and how like young people are trying to
put something together with the shared
vision thank you Christina
as Christina has mentioned before many
of us tend to have some misconceptions
before coming actually to the refugee
camps or due to the lack of connection
with the actual people there and what we
wanted to uncover something also in our
competition to uncover something that's
beyond the hardships and sufferings that
we see in newspapers and media's what we
want is to explore the actual life and
opportunities and people's wishes the
beautiful things and hopes behind and we
want to explore the life that
inhabitants there actually strive to
pursue and dream of so that's why we
have the marketplace the reason is that
many of the traditional aid
organizations they are able and they try
very hard to provide food shelter to
refugee inhabitants but however are many
of the needs of inhabitants for example
the need for opportunities the need to
really strive with their own abilities
are ignored or not addressed fully and
we consider that a marketplace is a
place where knowledge exchange and
information exchange and a lot of
communications learnings and many many
other amazing things happened and so we
want to use the marketplace as a nexus
within the refugee community to allow
people to learn and growth and shine but
don't get me wrong there are already
quite some marketplaces and several of
the refugee camps we have addressed
however those are marketplaces are kind
of dispersed not very well organized or
sometimes they're not able to address
the needs of the vulnerable groups in
the community so for our competition we
have picked three refugee camps with
very very distinct features one in
Berlin Germany and one in Kakuma Kenya
and one is of Terry Jordan they have
very very different demographic and
actual conditions
that's one of the very interesting
points of the competition is that we
actually provided some recommended
readings to the participants to allow
them to get some idea about what's
actually going on there
so for each competition for each
submission of which participants are
they have to submit two things the first
is a graphic design which is about
implementation the design and many
beautiful drawings and design for the
camp
however our competition is not just
about architecture it's more about a
visible and scalable sustainable project
so that's why we also require them to
submit a operational plan which may
include some technology aspects or how
to implement the technology or some
business aspects on calculating the
revenues houses famous thing about the
project was and everything has to be
done under a budget of a hundred
thousand years so before talking about
submissions we have received we have we
should step back a little bit to talk
about at the goal of our competition we
are not just about wanting to pick the
best proposals the best designs we we
also want to allow more people to
actually engage in the conversation
between the inhabitants so before the
deadline about our submission we hosted
three webinars to allow people at the
general public and also the participants
to actually talk to people who have
worked there and to clear some of the
myths or stereotypes for the Germany
site we have Alicia who once wasn't here
in Berlin and she discussed that some of
the marketplace in berliner actually it
is bruised and many of the facilities
were probably not as good as one might
imagine and fukakuna never Luongo who
was actually himself a Congolese refugee
living in Kenya is currently studying in
University in Nairobi he should the
experience that we shouldn't treat
refugees as just objects they have their
dreams they have their ambitions and we
have to give opportune
is to them so as they can fulfill their
potential either I was about longer is
just accepted by you know Georgia
University in Washington DC and he will
be fully like financially supported to
attend the graduate school the human
development projects there and also if
you are interested in learning about the
webinars you can log in to YouTube it's
all free it's all there it's amazing and
we have by February by the deadline of
the competition they have received three
hundred forty three submissions from 155
universities and 34 countries and
regions and so this posed challenge of
was we spent weeks and weeks a lot of
time in reading through the submissions
and we picked 26 finalists and in order
to pick the best among the 26 finalists
we seek help from a very strong
multidisciplinary juror team we have
experts from the World Bank economists
from the World Bank with ambassadors to
the United Nations we have leaders and
think tanks
we have university professors from
public policy public health economists
posix international relations and we
also have business people so those
people are not only reveal our proposal
not only marked them but they actually
came together at Yale and also
un-habitat interior office to discuss
face to face and to exchange your ideas
on what kind of plans are most visible
and I'd like to introduce the three
winners of the competition the first
winner is the digital platform
addressing some of the problems in
Berlin are they realized that from the
religious settlement in Berlin a kind of
dispersed and that's why it not only
offered that physical hub which includes
places were workshop for art where
events for internet connections but also
a digital market platform which is
accessible using scanning QR code and
Internet across all refugee settlements
in in Germany and this is very amazing
because the plan was able to connect
every
refugee settlements in Berlin using the
internet and this is a marketplace
online and the second winner addresses
some of the problem is in Kakuma is that
the proposal realized that food footage
is not a major concern however the lack
of technology to restore and cooling
food it's one of s one serious problem
that actually affects people's living so
they propose a very technology-based
proposal on operating a low budget local
low carbon food storage and cooling
device which basically uses water to
store food more effectively the third
proposal is for is a hard hard and it's
a woman's purse are it realized that
only four percent of the other shop
owners in the refugee camps where was
actually female and they decided to
build a marketplace that can provide a
safe and safe environment for the people
to actually do business and realize
fully realize their potential and our
competition will conclude in April 22nd
which is next Saturday at New York
University Law School and we will not
only have the three teams actually
coming to the United States to meet
ensure about the proposals to design we
have also involved righted a
multidisciplinary panel to discuss the
issues involved in related themes we are
very excited to see your order thank you
I um I don't have a slide for my part of
the presentation um but I will be
speaking about the Yale refugee project
which unlike ideation is an
undergraduate organization composed of
Yale undergraduates and local refugees
so the Yale refugee project began in
2008
- at the time foster awareness about the
global refugee crisis through direct
assistance to the local New Haven
refugee population and eventually
through advocacy events it's kind of
hard to believe now especially us who
are at this conference - did you think
that back in 2008 some people weren't
aware of the fact that there was this
growing population of displaced people
and so the refugee project was kind of a
response to that and also a response to
learning about the local refugee
resettlement agency iris we kind of
exist primarily because of our
relationship with the local refugee
resettlement agency integrated refugee
and immigrant services the resettlement
agency is kind of the final step of
refugee resettlement in the US and helps
integrate refugee families into the
community that they've been assigned in
this case New Haven the what the er
effigy project the way we have organized
ourselves is in two different branches
so one of them is direct assistance
which is the direct partnership with
iris and the other is advocacy which has
taken different forms direct assistance
has transformed over time it began with
having one Yale student be paired with
one local refugee family and having them
the Yale student kind of a system in any
way that was possible and so some things
that people did it would be help
refugees with their English or show them
around New Haven um it was very informal
and really varied pair by pair but
because that experience is very
different for each refugee and each real
student I kind of switched to one or two
Yale students with a young refugee so
that it didn't the problem of for
example
audience feeling responsible for any
sort of big issue that the family was
facing that kind of was removed and it
became more of a friendship between Yale
students and refugee youth but this year
in order to make it even more uniform
and less of it you know discrepancy in
experiences among the pairs we've turned
to a group of Yale students and a group
of refugee youth and well we have our
leadership in our Yale student group
there's also a leadership group in the
refugee on youth group and it's the Yale
undergrad who through our funding as
part of a Yale undergrad Jorgen ization
and our funding enjoy all we can put on
events on a bi-weekly basis for this
group to me and now our primary
intention is for Yale students and the
refugee you to develop a friendship and
to feel more comfortable interacting
with each other and so some of the
activities that we've had are mostly
like social events so we have a
Halloween party a holiday party we've
had picnics out on Lighthouse Point Park
we are having an art workshop for the
refugee the younger refugees and we've
we've had soccer so one thing we've kind
of come across is that even within
refugee youth there is the problem of
kind of gender segregation and even
though we intend for Yale students to be
partner with refugee use of both genders
sometimes it's easier to get the refugee
guys to come out instead of on the
refugee girls and so we've also had like
women-only events with like tea and
where they can bring like their younger
siblings this relationship with the
refugee local refugee population
has kind of made way and helped us
develop the advocacy program so knowing
and interacting and being in
conversation with the local refugee
population not only informed us and what
to do as far as advocacy is concerned
but also really inspires us I think it's
easier for people to really care about
refugee issues if they've interacted
with refugees themselves and so our
advocacy and awareness program has kind
of changed shifted with in response to
like the political climate and national
concerns about refugees and last year we
did some fund raisers and supported iris
the refugee resettlement agency in their
fundraiser efforts we've held panels at
faculty and talks it wasn't until the
end of last year and this year that we
kind of shifted more to her
demonstrations and within that two kinds
of demonstrations so we like to think
that what we did more of last year was
community building demonstrations and so
we held a photo campaign that we ended
up like sharing with the iris youth that
we work with already and we are we did
we are in the middle of doing a like
national project called Project welcome
which is similar on it's trying more to
express support to refugees and then the
other part of these demonstrations is
are more political ones
and so that kind of emerged in response
to the election and inauguration of
President Trump and so that kind of was
more of social media social media press
or social media presence
we worked with some people at the law
school and help them organize the vigil
that was held in response the
inauguration I remembers like we
rented a car and went out to the to the
JFK Airport we really put a lot of
effort into getting as many Yale
students to go to the not only to run
for Refugees for iris but also the March
for Refugees that followed and so this
was all kind of again more it shifted in
light of what was happening we some of
our members was also able to in an
effort to kind of expand outside of just
advocating for the local refugee
population we were trying to get some of
our members to learn more about not only
resettle refugees but asylum seekers who
are currently being detained at the
us-mexico border and so with the yell
international releases relations
association which is another
undergraduate organization we were able
to fund a small trip to see the
detention centers and see the community
response there the community response to
asylum seekers which again are different
and less privileged in some senses and
resettled refugees I think the biggest
takeaway from having been in the ER fu G
project and seen how it's grown and kind
of see the potential that it has what I
mentioned before is that Yale students
and probably this can be extrapolated to
any person you'll students are more
willing to act if they know the
community members themselves and can
participate unless of like this like
Saviour role and more in a reciprocal
relationship so part of the direct
assistance program the reason that it
has turned into what it is now is that
it's not only Yale students feeling like
they're like helping these refugees who
live in New Haven but the refugees
themselves are teaching us things and
having a say in what it is that we do
for social events and feeling more like
they have the authority to not only like
navigate New Haven but come on to Yale
campus and use its resources as well
another take away has been that like
young refugees in comparison to their
parents are more able or more prepared
to integrate into the communities that
they've been resettled in especially
here in New Haven so it may be more
feasible to work with the refugee youth
as opposed to again the adults um
it's easier because they're learning
English they're going to school and in
some ways are still kind of developing
their own identity and so it becomes
easier especially also if it's another
like young person interacting with them
through this project that is still
ongoing project Welcome which I will
talk about for one sec second is that
the project welcome is a coordination of
60-plus University campuses to create
this really really big canvas that is
signed by University students and that
will be displayed at different Airport
with will be displayed for the arriving
refugees which will hopefully continue
to happen and one takeaway from that is
that college campuses do you have a lot
of potential to liaison
like the resources of the university and
like local refugee populations in
different places I realized that college
campuses can also kind of begin their
own refugee projects and if there isn't
a resettlement agency in their vicinity
they can't do the direct assistance part
of this but they could do the advocacy
part one big struggle with trying to
advocate for refugees for example in on
like conservative places in the u.s. the
issue is advocating for them is that we
are here in Connecticut
we are affiliated with Yale you're
affiliated with like you know we're
considered liberals and so advocating
for them in really conservative places
there's it's a little it's a little
difficult but if if college campuses in
those locations or able to themselves
start their own like advocacy programs
they would have more authority in those
populations to to advocate for resettle
refugees there so yeah the your effigy
project is again undergraduate and some
next things that we want to do is
reproduce the same model and other
college campuses because right now the
we there's only the Euro refugee project
and the Wesleyan refugee project and so
we are again kind of hoping in that
expands thank you I just say wow what
amazing work that you guys are doing is
just incredible stuff you just how much
time do we have no matter it is oh okay
great so with it yeah but that questions
yes yeah
I just wanted to thank you for taking on
this amazing project it's not every day
that you see young people like yourself
involved in their community and making
such amazing things often time decisions
about the large disenfranchised majority
are made by the few oligarch and often
time we don't ask the input of the
people being served in your presentation
you talked a lot about refugees are not
object we asked them what they wanted so
you really did take the input of the
people you are working with I thought
that was really impressive just really
giving you a round of applause for your
amazing work then when you went to Kenya
I just wanted to ask if you face any
challenges I mean that was an incredible
journey for you too you mentioned I was
working on around the street and I met
two people that I had a condition with I
mean that's just incredible who does go
to another country and and I know in
Congo they don't really speak English I
mean maybe very few people what French
is very dominant and Lingala in Swahili
did you face any challenges language
barriers cultural barriers and how do
you overcome those thank you very much
thank you for the encouragement and it's
been very important for me to like hear
other people encourage me because haha
yeah and it's great to always like see
other people making the same effort with
me thank you very much
yeah so my first challenge of course was
I couldn't go get access to the refugee
camp because no one would grant me the
access people often look down unlike the
actual power a college student would
have especially as an individual so I
think I'm glad that I used what I did to
disprove that on that like college
students can do something especially as
individuals and you go out like insert
your thought and then you make something
happen and in terms of other challenges
I think um there was definitely a lot of
problems was like being alone in another
country I think I felt very secure
because I went with the OU fellowship
and I had a lot of resources from the
like literally from like all of the
world so I'm really grateful for that
but also I think whenever if you set up
your mind to do a project like this you
always have to have an open mind you
don't go in with any pre assumptions
you're always going with an open heart
and learn from other people so I felt
like I had a very open attitude towards
all the encounters I had like negative
ones positive ones I was like I was in a
deadly flood in Kakuma refugee camp and
I got involved with the local tribe
people because they were trying to get
money from me by taking me through a
land bridge filled with water and it's
like in the process if they release my
arms I would just be for like I would
just be like flooded down the riverbed
and then like die somewhere but there's
like there interesting experience that
I'm willing to learn from yeah it's like
a life lesson if you don't if you're not
willing to take the risk then there's
nothing much you can like actually go
out and achieve so I think I think once
you set up your mind you just have to go
with it so I think I was really lucky to
be able to feel that way the whole time
I was very glad I was very glad to hear
that you're you guys are open to
collaborate with the other universities
in New Haven because um as I saw then
graduates sometimes I feel like y'all
forgets that there are other three other
universities in New Haven Alberta's
southern and the University of New Haven
so I was really glad to hear that and I
maybe I'll share that information with
them my former professors and how they
can get in contact with you because um
you know we have iris here in New Haven
is making a big impact and on refugee
lives in New Haven so I think yel is
doing great work but with the four of us
coming together we would definitely do
you know greater work so I'm wondering
how soon are you
wanting to collaborate with the other
universities in New Haven and what do
you guys hope to accomplish yeah I think
that this will probably not so it's it's
hard with um finding people who will
commit their University to participate
and I really don't know I don't have a
timeline right now but it'll probably I
mean it would be this year this calendar
year but probably not this school year
next academic you have you tried
reaching out to like the professor
chairman of political science you know
public health chairman anthropology
Chairman so you know the way this is
worth is reaching out your students um
and that is kind of hard but I think
that is a great idea to begin with
faculty and they can maybe be better at
identifying students who would be ready
to participate Thanks my question is to
Maria as well have you found the refugee
community open to coming on campus or
was it easier to go to iris from my
personal experiences I invited refugee
families a number of times to attend
Arabic speaking events and they wouldn't
come so what what was your experience
this so that's where um yeah that um
when the RFE project first started years
ago that was a problem we face is that
we wanted to do something on campus but
people realize that a lot of the refugee
families were not very comfortable
coming to campus and so that's why it
became a Yale student goes to the
refugee families home with the shift to
working with
Fiji youth it has become much easier and
also the history so now I think every
refugee youth that has gone through iris
knows about the yah refugee project or
has been invited to participate in our
companion program and with that like
having established those relationships
it is that we've seen more refugees our
age come and then for like example it's
been very few events but the holiday
party the Halloween party and the t's
are what usually brings families here so
I think it it is difficult but the youth
the people our age can be a gateway into
really making the families feel more
welcome on the campus what are two more
questions continue the conversation
upstairs we're process of actually a DCG
projects and ideation are set and you're
welcome to join for reception and thank
you for being here thank you very much